[Music]
across all cultures and people humans
have always had one enduring question
what happens to us after we die as soon
as we figured out what death is and that
all humans die excluding some very
special anomalies we started wondering
what comes next is there some kind of
heaven or hell are we judged based on
our deeds in this life or is it just
purgatory for all eternity assuming of
course that there's anything at all
maybe it's just nothingness who knows
some people who have had near-death
experiences like being hit by a truck or
having their heart stop report going
into the afterlife but almost all these
claims were retracted or debunked and of
course there's the famous white light on
the other side of the tunnel that people
say precedes death the human fascination
with death extends beyond that too
mythologies all have their own
interpretations of what happens after
the physical body stops functioning the
ancient greeks believed in hades a realm
ruled by the god of the same name where
the souls of the dead would go to be
separated into those who were good in
life and those who were bad the good
would feast for eternity in elysium
while the bad would suffer horrible and
poetic punishments depending on what
they did the ancient egyptians also
believed in an underworld of the dead
though theirs was different from their
greek cousin they believed in the dwarf
which was pretty similar to egypt itself
it had plains lakes rivers deserts dead
souls would travel down the nile river
to face judgment and either be rewarded
or obliterated many egyptian gods and
goddesses were also said to reside in
the dwarf and some cultures don't
believe in an afterlife at all at least
not how most do tibetan buddhists
believe in a cycle of reincarnation when
someone dies their soul is reborn in the
body of a new living thing one can be
reincarnated as another human a plant an
animal or even an insect what you're
reincarnated into depends on your deeds
in your past life interacting with other
reincarnations and you can only escape
the cycle of death and reincarnation by
reaching spiritual enlightenment nirvana
needless to say many cultures have their
unique interpretation of what happens to
the soul and the spirit after your body
dies but there's no proof or way to
confirm anything so it's all confined to
the realm of belief there's no way to
reach into the afterlife and speak to
someone to find out what it's like or
is there well that definitely sounds
like an anomaly to me doesn't it but the
scp foundation doesn't just have one
anomaly related to what happens after
you die some of you may have seen our
video on scp-2718
what happens after death it's an anomaly
very very few people know about the long
and short of it is that
scp-2718 is a cognito hazard once you
learn about it it infects you and when
someone infected with it dies their mind
and soul stay intact after they die but
they can't move their body so they're
cursed into staying perfectly conscious
and aware of every nerve and sensation
in the body even as they're buried and
decompose over decades without being
able to do anything about it horrible
isn't it totally and that's why you
should watch it immediately after you
finish this video luckily the scp-2718
file is safely quarantined and buried in
the database it can't be excised
completely but making it so that only a
handful of people ever have a chance of
stumbling upon it is the best the
foundation can do to contain this
anomaly as for those people who do well
what can you do for a very very long
time the o5 council thought that
scp-2718 was the definitive answer to
the question of what happens after death
but another anomaly discovered several
years later overturned that answer
scp-2922 notes from the under
scp-2922 isn't anywhere near as heavily
classified as scp-2718
so we can read it safely without
worrying about infecting ourselves which
is pretty good considering what it can
do but let's get into it
scp-2922 is a euclid-class anomaly and
consists of three parts
scp-2922-a which is contained under high
security at area 2922 a small facility
built especially to contain it 24 hours
a day seven days a week one staff member
from project corbinic has to be in its
containment chamber to answer any calls
that might come from it in case you
weren't aware korbonic is the name of
the castle where legends say the holy
grail is kept and was discovered by king
arthur maybe
scp-2922-a is connected to it
scp-2922-c also needs to be researched
by scp-2922-b
due to its importance to foundation
operations scp-2922-b
seems to be some kind of person in that
case but what does any of this mean you
see
scp-2922 is a method of communication
between a human brain and a telephone
more specifically it's a kind of concept
what the foundation would call a memetic
cognito hazard those are big words but
think of them as forbidden knowledge
once you learn them they affect how you
think and you're able to act differently
because of them you do this in real life
too when you study something in a
textbook you're suddenly able to use
knowledge you didn't have before the
only difference is
scp-2922 allows you to do something
anomalous with it namely when a subject
is implanted with
scp-2922 in a secretive procedure they
can use their mind to call a phone
number a specific phone number has to be
chosen but it can be any number you want
imagine being able to dial up your
friends or family without using a phone
and imagine your phone ringing only to
learn it someone talking from their mind
nifty but this doesn't seem terribly
dangerous right the foundation isn't
quite sure how it works after performing
research involving
scp-2922 infected subjects calling phone
numbers they've detected that no radio
waves or communication signals are
involved which is part of why it is an
anomaly but how would something like
this be created well
scp-2922 was created years before the
foundation ever heard of it by a small
software development company they were
trying to create an app that would allow
you to send messages to people and
somehow accidentally created an app that
was telepathic it could send messages
from the mind when they realized what
they'd created they got scared and
abandoned and buried the project
destroying all their copies of the app
while almost all the foundation heard
about the project several years later
and managed to locate a single remaining
copy of the
scp-2922 program from the depths of the
company's archives even though it's an
app it can be used to call landline
phones too which is exactly what the
foundation did after a few more months
of research and experimentation they
confirmed that the app wasn't using the
electric signals of the brain like the
company had thought it was actual real
telepathy they even managed to create an
scp-2922 connection between a researcher
and an office telephone that's what the
sub-anomalies are
scp-2922-a is a simple landline phone
the kind you'd see in a receptionist
desk or in someone's office space it's
the designation number that scp-2922-b
can call into scp-2922-b
is of course the human element of
scp-2922
but the foundation only had one chance
at success at this experiment because of
the singular copy of the app so instead
of choosing a random d-class who
couldn't be trusted or might ruin the
test they had one researcher volunteer
to be host to scp-29k
dr janet spiegel a woman who had been
with the foundation's research division
for over a decade she was approved and
implanted with scp-2922
but what is
scp-2922-c well that's dr spiegel's
current location as of november 11 2014.
the foundation believes she's not on
this earth anymore or even in this
reality but located in an extra
dimensional location you see only two
months after dr spiegel was implanted
with scp-2922
tragedy struck while driving to work her
car was rammed by a drunk driver killing
her instantly but only two hours later
the scp-2922-a
phone began to ring the researcher
picked up the phone first answering that
the caller had the wrong number but was
interrupted by dr spiegel thanking god
someone had picked up the doctor thought
it was a prank call but dr spiegel
quickly rattled off her name email
password and social security number
after her credentials were verified the
researchers were incredulous they had
just heard that her car had been in an
accident and that she had died dr
spiegel confirmed that the only thing
she could remember was driving through
snow and rain and seeing a bright light
coming toward her and then she woke up
in the middle of a wide flat desert then
it hit her that she really was truly
dead and wouldn't be coming back before
promising to call back in a few minutes
she explained she needed time to process
the reality of her situation to the
sympathetic co-workers meanwhile the
overseer council approved project
corbinic a foundation operation to use
dr spiegel as scp-2920
to explore and catalog what scp-2922-c
was if she really was dead then that
would mean the strange desert she was in
was the afterlife the research team was
informed of their new assignment and the
next day they began to call in to dr
spiegel at first they just wanted to
figure out the landscape of the strange
dimension during the first call they
interviewed dr spiegel on her
surroundings she was still in the large
white desert and the sky was a dark sea
green with black clouds and no stars but
the most obvious features were three
large white moons floating in the sky in
place of the sun it was cold about 10
degrees celsius cold enough to make her
shiver but no wind anywhere she couldn't
see any other signs of life no animals
no people no wind no sound at all it was
completely silent except for her
breathing she still had her body though
when asked about how she felt she
couldn't feel pain hunger or even a need
to do anything but before they could
continue she asked if she could speak to
her husband the researchers told her
they'd need to talk to the o5 council
about it and that they tried to convince
them dr spiegel missed her husband and
they were sure he felt the same about
his wife then she offered a plan she'd
walk infinitely in one direction until
she saw something other than desert then
she'd call them again the researchers
agreed and dr spiegel hung up the phone
five whole days after that call the
phone rang again the researchers picked
it up only to hear
scp-2922 out of breath and panting when
asked what happened she started to
explain she had been traveling through
the desert for five days though this
place had no day night cycle and she
hadn't felt tired or hungry then she
encountered a mountain range and began
to approach its base when she saw a life
form but it wasn't human it walked on
two feet and looked like a mammal but
that was it it was some kind of gigantic
primate like a massive gorilla it easily
dwarfed the mountain she saw and had to
be at least two kilometers tall she had
felt it before she had seen it huge slow
footsteps shaking the ground then sod
exit the mountain range she saw it had
matted black fur and two huge glowing
white eyes with no mouth but then it
stepped on her not aggressively just out
of curiosity it seemed to be
investigating her and seeing how much
force she could withstand she was
crushed flat of course but only a few
seconds later her body put itself back
together and she was back to normal then
it lost interest and went off into the
desert she had just come from the
researchers were incredulous at this
seeming confirmation that scp-2922-c
was the afterlife but they were
interrupted by dr spiegel saying that
she could see people making campfires in
the valley ahead hundreds of them
huddled up and some buried halfway into
the ground the researchers guessed they
were trying to escape their situation
and dr spiegel worried aloud that she'd
wind up like them then she made another
request citing the service she had been
competently performing with full loyalty
that she be allowed to speak to her
husband but the o5s had already decided
that she would only be authorized to
speak with other project coordinate
personnel she asked the foundation to
hire him but with an art history degree
he wouldn't be of use to the foundation
beyond this one anomaly angrily she
swore and hung up the phone next time
they heard from her the call was brief
and icy dr spiegel was clearly still
angry over being denied the right to
speak to her husband but claimed she had
good news a wagon being driven by a
skeletal horse and a tall man in a white
robe had come to the human camp he
informed them that they were being taken
to a place called the elysian fields
remember elysium the greek afterlife
from earlier dr spiegel did and believed
that the man was taking them to a sort
of paradise the researchers remarked
that she didn't seem very happy but she
quickly hung up the phone after that
strange exchange
scp-2922 didn't ring for a very long
time no further transmissions came in
for seven months all attempts to phone
dr spiegel instead rang and rang but
were never picked up project korbenick
was put on hold until one day a
voicemail came to scp-2922-a
the voicemail was recorded by dr spiegel
but was different in tone from the other
calls it seemed angry she explained that
she had been keeping an eye on the
foundation's efforts to track her down
using the fact that she had gained the
favor of some kind of powerful godlike
entity she told the foundation about the
possibility of an elysium afterlife a
paradise and then knew that they'd want
more she had lied about the grim reaper
but everything else had been entirely
true but what happened after she visited
the human camp was in her words far too
complicated to explain but she would be
more than happy to answer the
foundation's questions of what happens
after you die for a small price if the
o5 council let her speak to her husband
she'd tell them everything but if they
weren't willing to accept one civilian
then she'd know and would never tell
them the real answer she signed off
ending the voicemail the researchers
were shocked at this sudden betrayal and
forward the request up the ladder but by
the time the 05 council began
deliberating on whether to involve her
husband in
scp-2922 something else happened
foundation researchers tracked another
voicemail coming from the same kind of
anomaly except it was going to herman
spiegel's house dr spiegel's widowed
husband figuring that she was trying to
contact her husband mobile task force
psy-8 the silencers raided his home but
as soon as they threw open the door and
moved in mr spiegel threw the phone
towards the wall to destroy it and was
shot by the soldiers the phone however
was unharmed and still had one voicemail
on it that the foundation was able to
extract the voicemail was from
scp-2922-b
janet spiegel talking to her husband at
first she was assuring him that he
wasn't insane and that he really was
hearing his wife from beyond the grave
then told him to listen carefully while
she explained the same godlike entity
she had befriended had worked some magic
to allow her to contact a phone besides
scp-2922-a
one time she told him that a foundation
task force was headed to his house and
would be there within 10 minutes not
just any task force psy-8 a squad
dedicated to black ops executions there
wasn't time to run he would die but she
reassured him that all wasn't lost even
though the situation must be terrifying
she knew he was an atheist but she was
proof that there was an afterlife and
not just one
millions of afterlives and the one she
was in was preferable to most of the
others most importantly her husband
could join her he already knew how to
get to the afterlife even if he didn't
remember he'd figure it out on the way
her husband listened to her instructions
with rapt attention she advised him on
the path he should take once he got to
the desert he should follow the moon on
the left until he reached the valley
where the striders the massive primates
dwelled there he should ask one of the
trees where she had gone and follow that
path she also advised him not to do
anything to anger anyone let the
striders kill him it's their way of
saying hello he'd regenerate with no
harm done but there were fates worse
than death that he should avoid at all
costs getting sent back for one but
before she could finish her advice both
of them realized that the mtf were at
his door hurriedly telling him to delete
the voicemail so the foundation wouldn't
find out she assured him that she had
help from her godlike friend and that
she fully believed in him and that he
should never give up she told him she
loved him forever by shooting mr spiegel
the mtf had inadvertently sent him to
scp-2922-c
along with his wife but the foundation
wasn't done yet
scp-2922 had let them set up operation
galahad a project to send train
foundation operatives into the afterlife
to try and apprehend janet spiegel
before she could bring down the
foundation operation galahad has plenty
more stories where that came from but
we'll cover those a different day now go
check out
scp-2718 what happens after death and
project damarang
scp-3448 half-death mri machine for more
anomalous afterlife action from scp
explained